let's talk about fouchy fouchy roasted
as fraud and liar after being confronted
by damning study on masks so how odd Oh
weird let's take a look at this let's
take a look at this un fouchy you know
what he's doing this time fouchy okay so
uh Dr anthon fouchi faced backlash on
social media after admitting on CNN that
a study showed masks had limited impact
on the overall course of the co 19
pandemic while acknowledging weaker data
for pandemic wi effect foui maintain
that individual level studies indicated
masks could offer some protection
critics including Senator Rand Paul and
commentators seized on fouchy statement
labeling him a fraud and a liar they
highlighted the apparent inconsistency
of his stance masks working individually
but not on a larger scale leading to
accusations of deception and mistrust
fouchi shifting mask guidance during the
pandemic also fueled controversy
initially downplayed mask Effectiveness
due to shortages later endorsing them as
supplies increased Vinnie uh well first
I I've been calling him flip-flop fouchy
for for the longest time it's like okay
he's retired am I am I right Rob he's
finished he's not even supposed to be
it's just weird that now that all the
stuff that we're hearing about is this
the clip by the way this is the clip and
P do me a favor while while he plays
this look at how creepy this guy's eyes
are on the lip but look at look at
fouchi a retired guy but they keep
willing him out whenever something about
comes out uh Brett Stevens in the times
talked about Cochran put that on the
screen the most rigorous and
comprehensive analysis of scientific
study conducted on the efficacy of masks
for reducing the spread of respiratory
illness including coid 19 was published
last month its conclusions said Tom
Jefferson the Oxford epidemiologist who
is the lead author were unambiguous
there is just no evidence that they
masks make any difference he told the
journalist mayanne deasi full stop but
wait hold on what about the n95 masks as
opposed to the lower quality surgical or
cloth masks makes no difference none of
it he said well what about the studies
that initially persuaded policy makers
to impose Mas mandates they were
convinced by non-randomized studies
flawed observational studies how do we
get beyond that finding of that
particular
review yeah but there are other studies
Michael that show at an individual level
for individual when you're talking about
the effect on the epidemic or the
pandemic as a whole okay the data are
less strong you made no sense you just
said it's a nothing salad wait a minute
wait a minute individual level
individuals and by the way this just
came out I don't know if you saw this
this this thing just came out Vinnie if
you saw this here uh uh from CDC
apparently breaking CDC has stated that
Americans who have had received the MRNA
coid vaccines are now at a higher risk
of infection from new variants of the
virus than those who aren't vaccinated
so you're talking about Jill Biden P who
yesterday tested positive can you verify
this go forward Jill Biden uh D I'm
pretty sure vaccinated in every single
booster shot she's probably in line for
another booster but Pat this goes to my
question is Americans are we going to
are you going to comply when they try to
bring this back cuz you know it's coming
back these are the signs the uh first
lady Co you wheel out fouchy he's trying
to be like well I said it but I did but
I didn't say it I this is going to be a
beautiful test to see if Americans are
going to bow down and do exactly as
they're told again because it's starting
to come back uh Philadelphia is doing it
I'm seeing my my mom flew recently she
said people at the airport are already
starting to wear the mask it doesn't
work and I sent rob a video P of uh of
fouchi this is mid pandemic during the
pandemic saying on 60 Minutes mask
nobody during a pandemic should be
wearing a mask because they don't wear
rob you have that that little clip I I
uh I sent it to you it's like eight how
many times are we going to let these
people flipflop out time and then zero
accountability and why do we keep
willing him out he's retired
like get we don't want to see you
anymore could you show it really fast
right now in the United States people
should not be walking around with masks
you're sure of it CU people are
listening really closely to this right
now people should not be walk there's no
reason to be walking around with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people feel a
little bit better and it might even
block a a droplet but it's not providing
the Perfect protection that people
people think that it is so so
interesting that what was the date that
was probably March of 2020 mid pandemic
so it's but no no not mid like very
early right March of 202 very early but
but even does it does it matter if the
head M hey that's Mr science says you
don't it doesn't work if it doesn't work
then what's the point and then but Adam
my real question I'm being genuine then
what what is it is it a show of their
power of like they could mess with us
whenever they want cuz if it doesn't
work what's the point why good question
I think look as the um the President
George W bush once said you know fool me
once uh you can't uh trist You Can't Get
Fooled Again tourist uh you know you
know fool me once yeah uh shame on you
fool me uh twice shame on me so look I
think what happened to co just taking
like kind of a step back it was so new
it was so weird we've never seen
anything like this first time in a 100
Years of pandemic people are told to
trust the science you know operation W
speed Trump you got fouchy out there
doing his thing it's just like you have
uh Dr Burks out there people didn't have
no clue no clue they're tell oh get a
shout don't get a shout I don't know you
got to travel if you want to leave the
country got TR like but I feel to use
the George W bush then Can't Get Fooled
Again yeah uh I feel like if this
happens again yeah people are like nah
bro you you really have that much faith
in the average American I do okay I
don't they're going to they're going to
bow down and this comes down to what I
was going to say
there's a difference between choice and
mandates I think we can all agree this
is not a country where mandates play
well if you want to get vaxxed if you
want to wear a mask if you want to put a
face diaper on your face as they say
more power to you do your thing if
you're like n dude that's not for me I
don't want to get vaxed I don't play
that game then that's on you like look
Jill Biden has coid now yeah my mom just
got over Co yeah certain people close to
us in the vicinity of value tainment
have had coid it's a real thing yeah and
whether you get vaxed or whether you
don't get vaxed that's your choice but I
do not believe in mandate but you're and
I understand but you're saying that now
Adam what I'm saying is is when like you
said that chaos that Madness and then I
mean they knew what the hell was going
up they know what what the deal is they
were mandating it you couldn't fly you
Adam you remember if you on an airplane
and you even tried to lowerer your mask
they were on top of you right and some
people I saw I was on on a flight coming
here at him they kick the dude off he's
like I'm not going to I'm not I'm not
wearing a mask they kicked them off so I
mean we've changed my curiosity is when
it hits the fan again and it's coming
cuz the new ba whatever the for the
Sheep it's the new one let's see how
American Rob can you go back to what you
just pulled out when I said can you
verify this that one article let me read
this here based on what can you please
read that uh sure this is from cdc.gov
based on what CDC knows now existing
tests used to detect and uh detect and
medications used to treat coid 19 appear
to be effective with this variant
ba286 may be more capable of causing
infection in people who have previously
had coid 19 or who have received coid 19
vaccines and again that's from cdc.gov
that's from cdc.com that's the CDC so go
out and get unvaccinated so you'll be
safer yeah how do you do that but can't
geted again and here's my thing here
here's the here's what the average
American is thinking not conspir iry
theorist coincidence theorist isn't it
it's a weird coincidence that now we're
getting close to election year this is
the this is the test this is the oh
there's another variant put on the mask
the the the the first lady has it at
what point is it going to get that where
they're like oh God pandemic number two
is here you got to stay home nobody
leave your house vote from your house
and mail in ballot P that I'm telling
you guys right now that's where they're
leading up to I think let's wrap this up
with one thing you know the weatherman
can say can pop that um
Malik pop that one back up uh from CDC
we're going to go to the next to last
statement real fast um you know it can
rain or it can be a hurricane right and
right now it says here at this point
there is no evidence that this variant
is causing more serious more severe
illness there you have it so guess what
there is a direct link in all this to
herd immunity and that the variants out
there are not making people as sick as
they used to so when you say the word Co
it's not like saying rain versus
hurricane the Hurricane's over it may
rain and they rain for a couple days and
you get sick and come by the way PS
China still has not been held
accountable I'd like to just point that
out what the hell's going on in China
just going to point that out right there
is that weird we still pack to this day
wait you still can't even say that type
of stuff for being racist where is the
accountability for you know what was
what was the most funniest thing is when
when that one the time when Trump says
it's called the China virus and then
says sir you can't call it China that's
that's discriminating yes the whole
population we have in America and then
the journal is reporter who's Chinese
Asian lady says it's called CH why would
you say that to me would you say that to
me because I'm Chinese no it's because
it's from China and story comes out it's
from China you know okay so we G to go
back is that the one is that the one
play that's the one that can you just
play that that's not the AG no that's
not no I know it starts with that and
she's the last one got Go played from
the beginning she's cute watch this keep
calling this the Chinese virus there are
reports of dozens of incidents of bi
bias against Chinese Americans in this
country your own a secretary AAR says he
does not use this term he says ethnicity
does not cause the virus why do you keep
using this it comes from racist it's not
racist at all no not at all it comes
from China that's why that's why what
they don't have the asan lady Asian lady
was like why are you looking at me when
you're saying like China wow weird he
was right it's like in The 40-Year-Old
version like let's move on to the next
next story because we're not going to go
back to the history books and erase the
Spanish flu or erase the Hong Kong flu
or the great insult to pigs around the
world the swi flu so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here